here in the Bahamas with Brian and Sarah
bomber at the resorts through Lamar you
guys have got to give us the Grand Tour
oh we can't wait to give you the Grand
Tour okay well it's gonna be the way to
stay here right we don't actually get to
stay here this is one of our signature
villas obviously it is steps to the
ocean you wake up and you stare at that
ocean every day
I love the the pictures too on the walls
what are those from these are actually
original from the hotel when we were in
construction phase we found these photos
they were small 4x6
black-and-white photos and we've had
them blown up and completely retouched
and I think they're just a great nod to
the history of the island and in
particular this hotel
guys you can't beat this like cannot
beat this how many steps like 20 steps
from there and now we're here at the
oceans beautiful and I mean I would love
to get on the path where the Sun pouring
like you there's a ton of stuff here
right yeah we've got a water sports
center here so we have the Hobie Cat
we've got kayaks we've got paddle boards
we've got snorkeling gear we've got
fishing charters we've got a dive shop
on the island so anything you want to do
activity wise you can do if you just
want to pull up a chair under one of the
palapas and relax you can do that too
Carlos you feel a little a little
peckish blowing bite yeah I think we
should head up to the drift bar grab a
drink alright the Carlos here we are at
the drifts beach bar that's a little
more we are as you can see steps to the
beach we're right beside the pool we've
got a beautiful seating area there this
is where you come during the day to
relax kick back maybe have a burger and
have a drink yeah you're I mean you're
killing me with his burger Cerullo
burger it's pretty good I must have it
you can have our burger but you cannot
have our fries this is a quality control
thing just to make sure thank you yeah
of course
mmm yep definitely sold
hmm well no Resort is complete without a
beautiful pool of each neck and a
delicious cocktail so here you are I do
like how you can sit at the fire pit at
night watch some stars right that's
exactly it we've created some areas to
sit and dine during the day or
relaxation here in the evening well I
know about you guys but I can't wait to
spend the rest of the day relaxing by
your floor not a bad plan
I would agree so here's to relaxation
[Music]